formación en desobediencia civil Laura y
Lili quieren convertirse en activistas
contra el cambio climático del grupo
Última Generación en este patio trasero
de Berlín practican el bloqueo de
carreteras y el trato con automovilistas
enfadados
presión psicológica extrema hay mucha
violencia
tipo de acciones
nunca ha habido tantos candidatos para
la acción directa dice Simón su
entrenador Cuanto más nos reprimen más
se da cuenta la gente de que el gobierno
no se toma En serio la protección del
clima las fuerzas del orden sospechan
que Última Generación forma parte de una
organización criminal se han llevado a
cabo registros y se han congelado
cuentas bancarias desde entonces se han
celebrado manifestaciones de apoyo en
toda Alemania estamos aquí para decir
que la forma en que están siendo
tratados es inaceptable lo que está
haciendo el gobierno es desproporcionado
el movimiento ya anunciado que continúa
con sus tácticas de choque Esto hace
nuestra tarea mucho más difícil pero
estamos dispuestos a afrontar las
consecuencias judiciales no porque sí
sino porque los cimientos de nuestra
existencia se están derrumbando Pero los
activistas que han estado bloqueando
carreteras siguen en el punto de mira de
la justicia decenas de ellos han sido
condenados apenas de prisión políticos
de todos los partidos apoyan la acción
policial
un grupo de personas organizadas y
financiadas para preparar actividades
ilegales eso se llama una organización
criminal nadie dice que sea la mafia
pero tiene que acabar
magia
los simpatizantes han donado casi medio
millón de euros de ayuda de emergencia
al grupo suficiente para continuar su
lucha contra el cambio climático de
forma legal o ilegal
[Aplausos]